[Music]
this co-lead is making people great with
this guy's this group man yeah this
complete is getting people to come up
with new ideas on how they can keep
their businesses afloat and so that's
when this this one strip club Oh
in Portland it was I was wondering what
prostitutes were gonna do now that you
have to do social addition you should
prostitutes to do--make strippers are
some different processes always Omega
that's less than J less than ten cam
girls are [ __ ] reckon it Oh cam oh
yeah oh man I have a holy pant only
fantasia on the pants
it's just pants
easily by nonstick [ __ ] unzipper
with the button fly strip club in
Portland they announced that they will
be bringing dancers to your door in
their new food delivery service because
they also sell food at the strip club so
they are calling it Boober eats and the
guy said that the club owner said that
originally it was a joke but then once
he got a ton of shares on Facebook
that's when he was like well [ __ ] why
don't we just try to do this so what
they're saying is that they do have a
full menu of food menu and non-alcoholic
drinks like ginger beer and redbull that
are available for delivery and so how
much is it I don't know about the price
is it like three rolls of toilet paper
pretty expensive
yeah that's expensive so he's saying
that dancers will show up to your front
door and deliver you the food and they
will be in pasties and in booty shorts
and then they'll do a quick little dance
and then leave yeah that's it and then
you and you throw toilet paper at him
yeah I don't know like oh wow thank you
thank you don't be wasteful Steve all
yours you gonna use all of those so you
understand me oh do but the disturbers
are doing it in daylight like how you
had sex ii club lighting that like makes
everything look Oh like you're gonna see
how old they really are yeah actually
like Santa imperfections I likes I like
like the lightning marks stretch marks
like I like that lightning but like they
have to see the guy's face in full broad
daylight - yeah open the doors like yeah
I don't think they're gonna be on like
no actual offense no no no do it on a
porch yeah weird - like who would order
this service you can say people that
order the Molly mates not Molly maids
with the guy a new maid topless maid
just walk in right I know that there are
two people that come one person actually
does it clean it and then the top of six
it's like kind of death stuff around
that's funny
okay so what I'm saying is this is still
out in public like your neighbors are
viewing this like tiny little show with
pasties and maybe they have a
and it's like this way to you I like
that better okay what if you get tapas
mains but then you gotta go to work
what would you order it for while you
had the son of a [ __ ]
you can schedule a topless maid I can
I'm gonna work for this you got a ring
or in a game house that's pretty good
now you can watch it and feel like a
creep but you're not really being a
creep because it doesn't know like hey I
already paid for it so I'm just watching
it forward hey I'm over here hey I'm on
the table I wonder if they knew that it
was that creepy when they're recording
that song yeah he's like I want to write
something that you can kill somebody -
there's just no song right now for that
I want to fill that marketing what could
pedophiles and kidnappers use as a
ringtone I've never heard this song why
it is it is so creepy and a guy will you
see his face he looks like the type that
would write that song yes he is have you
ever seen the video he did it live on
his own deceive us yes this is him that
is [ __ ] him he is well we get to
monetize this might be a champion for
less than ten seconds oh my this is one
of the creepiest and he's playing a
banjo - this is like wrong everything
about that is creepy what is he British
look you do understand that this isn't
for us they are in the audience people
are like this like like 60,000 people
yeah trainee Tim everybody's licking
each other I feel like that's the type
of audio normally
I drove all Volkswagens there ah this is
what a creepy song and a creepy guy and
it got popular in the mainstream but
only like scary movies right nobody's
like putting it like cause the score for
like the mix boy's name if someone had
to find that song to put it in a movie
what is this
ukelele here we go Lane I'm sorry that's
not me I need to light a lot of bands
are you playing at the White House or
something we're flying
wait what's the banjo oh that's the it's
the round yes so I'm a Google and yeah
because that's a bit less in the winner
yeah you could serial kill two banjos
for sure yeah stop comment says it's all
fun and games until your security camera
plays this song right because that was a
story that was a story with this guy
remember people like hacking into people
whose rings and this dude he was like
hey you wanna be my best friend she was
like oh my gosh yeah yes the artist name
the name of the song is tiptoed through
the tulips to the tulips well he [ __ ]
up on that because the windows oh it
does I t's huh
oh here's
look at the wall yeah it sounds very
tropical he's the type of guy that sits
down to peace even if you walk in like
what are you doing tour the first year
we can't OD he's halfway to the bathroom
like a public bathroom I would get right
next to Cara at the urinal and I would
just put my pants all the way down
that's up our ass all the way explodes I
don't care who walked in and saw me I
just wanted to make you super uncool
well how would you have reacted though
if you pulled out his cell phone I
started like taking photos of you well
bless so there you go no I can talk with
me and set the bar like they try to do
they all good like they always tried to
do stuff like because I would like to do
the whole hold the elbow thing nobody
doesn't bother me and living like two
bit of Santa but I let me go
I like they're trying to rub my legs
like creeped me out but I'm like no but
higher go high and I move the hand I
forgot I can't play with you like is why
why it's the only one who will part with
Bart would kiss you and maybe even have
sex with you for the bit yeah they don't
win let me yeah it's crazy to think
about all the industries that are
completely [ __ ] because of all this
[ __ ] where I live like they'd like
nobody wants to put nobody in a car you
don't know like what the health status
is and then like you comedians I'm
[ __ ]
I'm totally [ __ ] only the only saving
grace I have right now is that I have
this new show called wording this heart
it's on YouTube right now check it on my
page Steve is actually on the episode
was doing great numbers thank you guys
so much but that is the only like win
for me and is that like people are
consuming so much content right
actually yeah like if it wasn't for this
new show coming out and like just the
other thing I gonna I would be
completely [ __ ] because every show has
been canceled that's for ya please watch
everything everyone is putting out watch
everything anything everywhere
everything this is why I want any links
you see on Instagram because they help
we are by any franchises than anything
anywhere yes anytime I get a car do your
favorite tubers get a gift card by by
one of their downloads or something
subscribe to their the patreon like I'm
my page honest I did yet but it's just
gonna be the literally have 1000
subscribers a week and a half ago
well page I might be a little harder to
sell because everyone's like [ __ ] yeah
true that's unlike just watch everything
it's free content watch and click on add
watch eternal calm slash Nicki watch
cheesy but as much manually watch
tipping case yeah
listen girl podcast well we put a whole
bunch of blogs about us moving into the
new house so if you want to look at oh I
have video ideas about things you could
do a home alone oh I'm gonna do a live
show
Oh videos what what a next video wait
big mood what we should they don't like
what
[Music]